bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
mon sur arte france alors pour les
sénateurs communistes que vous
représentez la réponse est oui il faut
rapatrier et toutes les troupes
françaises
oui nous pensons que l'opération barca
des dans l'impasse nous et tirons parti
au mali pour juguler la violence en tout
cas la violence terroriste islamiste
et ce qui se passe c'est au contraire
une expansion de cette violence
cinquante militaires français ont été
tués mais 5000 malien où sont morts
depuis 2015 plus de 4000 dans toute la
région pour la seule année dernière
donc il y à une extension de la violence
extrêmement préoccupante et nous voyons
bien que la solution militaire ne sera
pas une
donc nous pensons non pas retirer les
troupes demain matin mais nous pensons
qu'il faut maintenant programmé la fin
de l'opération marque anne et remplacer
cette opération par un autre agenda de
sécurité un agenda de coopération
politique économique qui permettent de
replacer la question du développement
qui est le mal profond des pays
africains l'aller le manque de moyens
pour le développement et bien refaire de
la question du développement la sole le
centre de la politique française en
afrique
c'est ce qui réglera selon vous la
question sécuritaire
elle ne réglera pas à elle seule la
question sécuritaire mais de gens tant
par développement d'abord de redonner
aux états africains les moyens de
maîtrise propres de leurs services
publics pour pouvoir les développer sur
tous les territoires de leur pays les
moyens de leur sécurité nationale avec
des armes et qu'ils puissent assurer
souverainement la défense de leur
territoire des moyens de justice en fait
des moyens de développement dans tous
les domaines qui permettront d'asseoir
des politiques sécuritaires stable
d'asseoir le développement de la
démocratie dans ces pays et de répondre
surtout aux besoins sociaux immense de
ce continent
il y à d'immenses ressources humaines et
en afrique qui sont aujourd'hui mises à
mal par les politiques de spoliation de
toutes parts qui appauvrissent les
populations et les extrémistes
islamistes font leur lit dans ce
désespoir et dont cette pauvreté
mais est ce que selon vous les pays
africains sont en capacité de régler
seule la situation au sahel
je crois qu'ils ont beaucoup plus de
moyens qu'on veut bien le dire mais
évidemment il faut agir dans beaucoup de
domaines et leur redonner les moyens
d'agir au lieu de les maintenir sous
tutelle vous savez nous avons posé une
question dans le débat qui est posée par
les africains eux mêmes la question des
flux financiers illicites issus de tous
les trafics qui nourrissent notamment le
terrorisme islamiste en afrique
eh bien ces flux financiers illicites
ses 88 milliards de dollars par an
c'est presque autant que l'intégralité
des aides au développement et des aides
internationales des investissements
étrangers en afrique
donc il y a énormément de richesse qui
fuit ce continent et il faut aider
l'afrique à lutter contre cela pour
avoir les moyens de son développement
et évidemment ça prendra du temps mais
justement ne prenons pas de retard parce
que les 1
invention militaires au lieu d'aider à
régler ses problèmes plein déstabilise
ce pays et aggravent les problèmes au
lieu de les résoudre
pour vous c'est la france se retire de
la région cela ne risque pas de faire
dégénérer la situation
non nous nous parlons de d'annoncer ce
départ et de le préparer
parce qu'évidemment aujourd'hui dans la
situation actuelle se retirer
brutalement aggraverait le chaos
donc il ne s'agit pas d'abandonner ces
pays au chaos
il faut donc programmé l'annoncé
construire un agenda de retrait et il
faut le construire avec les africains
avec l'union africaine avec l'onu avec
les pays concernés au premier chef le
mali il faut donc négocier un retrait
programmé et maîtrisée qui permettrait
de lui substituer de substituer à
l'opération barkan un autre agenda de
sécurité un autre agenda de
développement donc c'est une discussion
politique il faut que la politique
reprenne ses droits et pas seulement le
militaire tout le monde depuis le début
il dit depuis huit ans que nous sommes
là bas dit qu'il n'y aura pas de
solution militaire
et pourtant nous continuons à faire de
l'intervention militaire le coeur le
centre de notre politique avec le mali
c'est une erreur profonde et qu'elle
devrait être à cet âge en date de
retrait idéal que vous évoquez
écoutez ça justement je viens de vous le
dire il est à négocier avec avec les
africains mais nous savons aujourd'hui
que l'intervention française qui au
départ avait été saluée par les maliens
qui craignait le péril islamiste
aujourd'hui cette intervention est
rejetée pourquoi parce qu'elle n'a pas
endigué le péril islamiste qui continue
de se développer dans toute la région et
je voulais dit il y a des milliers de
morts issus des populations civiles et
des armées locales
depuis des années la situation empire le
danger des milices islamistes se répand
malgré la présence de l'armée française
et on voit des populations qui sont
entraînés dans cette guerre on voit des
des guerres communautaire reprendre dans
des régions où elles n'existaient plus
donc la situation dégénère
donc il faut se fixer l'objectif de
remettre au centre des choix politique
centré vers le fait d'accorder de donner
aux états les moyens de rang prendre
la maîtrise de leur territoire et de
progressivement faire de ces politiques
des politiques qui remplace la présence
militaire française
merci beaucoup d'avoir pris le temps de
réagir sur notre antenne pierre laurent
sénateur pcf de paris